Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings,
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
What you're gonna start
to experience is this cooling
and tingling.
Give me a kiss.
‐Ew!
I need a business ninja
in my corner.
We've done $1.1 million
in sales.
‐Yeah!
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
That's stupid money.
I'm not stupid.
This is "Shark Tank."
I could sell so much
of this on QVC.
‐No, he couldn't!
‐Absolutely.
‐He's bald.
‐Ooh.
I want you to say yes
right now.
‐What are you gonna do?
‐What do you feel in your gut?
Um...
My name is Tara Brown.
I live with my husband, Jason,
and my two kids,
Wesley and Clara.
My husband and I
are both doctors.
I'm an ophthalmologist,
and he's a cardiologist.
I don't think some people
realize what it actually takes
for a woman to get ready
in the morning.
There's hair, makeup,
and that's before
you've woken up the kids
to get them ready.
We're gonna be late.
My product is unique,
and it solves a near‐universal
problem for women.
Hey, Sharks.
I'm seeking $500,000
in exchange for 5% equity.
Okay, Wes,
what's the valuation?
My kids love "Shark Tank."
They know
all the Sharks by name,
and they definitely
have their favorites.
‐Put some more in there.
‐Thank you.
Being an entrepreneur has been
a great educational experience.
It teaches my kids
about self‐reliance,
which is very important to me.
I've invested $100,000
into this business.
It's scary because that
could be my kids' education.
My husband and I still have
student loans
after practicing for 10 years.
That's a lot of money.
We have a lot riding on this.
I'm representing all of us
when I go into the Tank,
so I cannot let them down.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tara Brown,
and I'm from San Diego.
I am seeking $75,000
in exchange for
a 20% equity stake
in my business.
Sharks, this video illustrates
a typical morning
for women everywhere.
The girl in pink
has to get her hair washed,
blown out, and styled
before she's ready to go.
But the girl in blue
used the Sleep Styler ‐‐
the roller that dries and styles
your hair while you sleep.
So she woke up
with her hair already done.
Wow.
The Sleep Styler girl has time
to actually enjoy her morning,
[ Chuckles ]
and is already out the door
while the other poor girl
is still styling.
The average woman spends
an hour a day on her hair,
but I spent just five minutes
putting these rollers in
after a relaxing bath
last night.
The Sleep Styler is made
with super‐absorbent
yoga‐towel fabric that
wicks moisture out of the hair
while remaining
dry to the touch.
The memory foam inside
is marshmallow‐soft
and ensures
a fabulous night's sleep.
The unique shape
maximizes air flow
and allows you
to curl or straighten.
Plus, the hair becomes
softer and shinier
once you lose
those damaging hot tools.
So, Sharks, who's ready to
curl up with the Sleep Styler?
Do you have samples?
I have samples.
'Cause I want
to try it tonight.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
I'm gonna grab one for Lori ‐‐
there's yours.
‐Thank you, Robert.
‐Thank you, Tara.
‐Got to zip it open?
‐You have gorgeous hair.
Thank you.
We want all
of your hair products.
O'Leary: So, Tara,
as you can imagine,
I spend a lot of time
in the morning making sure
every one of my hairs
is in place.
[ Laughter ]
But what really keeps me
awake at night
is thinking about sales.
So, tell me how much you've got
in sales on this thing?
So, I launched two months ago
on Kickstarter,
and I made my goal
in the first 12 hours,
and I closed the 30‐day campaign
at $47,000.
‐Oh, good for you!
‐Wow!
‐What was your goal?
‐$10,000.
Tearing it up, Tara.
And since then,
it's been for sale
exclusively on my website.
‐And how many have you sold?
‐And how much have you sold?
Um, that's been
three weeks ‐‐ $6,000.
Are you a hair stylist?
I'm an ophthalmologist.
‐Of course you are.
‐Well, that makes perfect sense.
Okay, I got to know.
How did the eye doctor
go to a hair doctor?
So, as a working mom,
I could never find time
to blow out and curl
my naturally frizzy hair.
You have frizzy hair?
Very frizzy hair.
I've tried every straightener,
the keratin,
and no‐‐ those all
just damaged my hair.
I was tired of every day
being a ponytail day.
Right?
Exactly, so...
[ Laughs ]
And even when I did
take the time to blow it out
and style it, my hair
was dull and dry
from all that heat damage.
Then one day, I was
taking a braid out of
my daughter, Clara's, hair that
I'd put in wet the day before.
And I was thinking about how it
still had that braid wave in it.
Mm, well said.
And it stayed that way
until she washed it again,
so I started thinking about
that quality of hair
that whatever shape it's in,
as it goes from wet to dry
is how it will stay.
And I wondered if I could
use that quality
to passively dry hair
to appealing shapes.
And when was that?
That was last summer.
Oh, you've done this
really fast.
So, I quickly realized that
I needed to make a sewn product,
but I didn't know how to sew.
So I enrolled in fashion school.
‐And I ‐‐
‐You enrolled in fashion school?
Yes, I ‐‐
What about
the ophthalmology practice?
I have that, too.
‐Why not?
‐And you're a mom.
‐And your kids...
‐How many days a week
do you do the ophthalmology?
‐I do surgery and see patients
three days a week.
The other four days
and all nights
are spent on my hair company.
And after finishing the first
semester of fashion school,
I was able to speak
knowledgeably
with my manufacturer about
things like seam allowances
and surged edges,
and so was able to create
a beautifully
constructed product.
That's so impressive.
What do you sell it for?
You're operating on eyes
one minute,
going to fashion school
the next...
Exactly.
...developing product,
and raise your kids.
That's incredible.
Tara, what do you
sell it for?
Uh, it retails for $39.
‐The package as we see here?
‐The package of eight.
‐And what does it cost you?
‐What does it cost you to make?
Delivered to San Diego, $9.94.
‐Wow, great margin.
‐Wow!
How much
have you invested?
I've spent $100,000
of my own money.
Oh, wow,
you're all in, then.
Well, can I ask you ‐‐
it's amazing to me.
In a year and a half, you were
a full‐time ophthalmologist.
‐Yes.
‐You have children.
‐And you got this business
off the ground.
How did you do that?
'Cause I can accomplish the work
of three people in one day.
So, Tara, why do you need
the $75,000?
You ‐‐ ophthalmologists
make good money, I assume.
Why didn't you
put it up yourself?
Uh, because that wouldn't
give me the value of a Shark.
I need a business ninja
in my corner.
What do you need
the most?
I took this product
to CosmoProf,
the world's biggest
beauty trade show,
where it really created
a frenzy.
Yeah, I've spoken there
the last couple of years.
I was approached
by Amazon Launchpad, HSN, QVC,
buyers everywhere
from Dubai to England.
And I, uh, want
to make the right decision.
I haven't signed anything yet.
You know, I love this.
First off, it feels like
a beautiful ultra‐suede.
It's a microfiber, it's plushy,
and really soft and comfortable.
I put it behind my head,
and I would want to sleep on it.
I think it's genius.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
One of my things is that
when I really want something,
I just go for it.
And I'm gonna apologize to
my fellow Sharks right now.
Well, there may be
other offers, Lori.
I'm gonna make you an offer,
and, uh, I'm gonna
try to shut it down.
So, I'm gonna make you an offer
of $75,000 for 30%.
I think this would be perfect
for QVC with me ‐‐
I'm gonna blow it out.
And I think it could be
a great infomercial item,
which I'm also expert at.
And I just want you
to say yes right now.
Wait, wait.
There's other offers coming.
It's an offer!
I could sell so much
of this on QVC.
It's an offer.
No, he couldn't!
Absolutely.
He's bald!
That's the point!
[ Laughter ]
‐What?
‐That's the point.
I'd be huge
on QVC with this.
Tara, I want you
to say yes right now.
I think you know if I would be
the right partner for you.
You don't have to say
yes right now.
You have four other Sharks
to hear from.
‐It's not fair...
‐Ooh.
...to just get stamped
for 30% of your equity...
‐I want it.
‐... when clearly there's
other Sharks interested.
‐I want to tell you something.
If you were going
into a prize fight,
you'd want a heavyweight fighter
that was in that,
uh, "weight," right?
‐Yes.
You would want somebody
who loves your product
as much as you do.
‐You want this thing.
‐And that's the kind of partner
that you want.
Um...can I make
a counter?
‐Yeah.
‐Of course you can.
I've never seen her this
excited about a product.
‐Yeah, counter.
‐Make a counter.
Yes.
‐Um...
25%?
Done.
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I want a happy partner,
and I want to blow it out.
Oh, my God.
That's the best product
she's bought this season.
‐Thank you.
‐That was everything for me.
When I saw it, I knew
instantly it's great.
‐Thanks, Tara. Congrats.
‐Thank you, Tara.
Thank you.
It was over really fast,
but I'm afraid if I took my time
and nickled and dimed,
I could've lost the offer.
So, I'm glad it worked out.
Narrator: Next up
is a unique way
to enjoy a favorite beverage.
♪♪
All right, Sharks.
So, who's up for
a great bottle of wine?
My name is Billy Dim,
and I'm the creator/owner
of Blendtique Wine Company.
My partners and I are seeking
$250,000 in exchange for
a 10% equity share
of the business.
Blendtique invites you
to participate
in a revolutionary new process
whereby the everyday consumer
can create and design
their very own
personalized wine blends
from the comfort of home.
Our signature blending kit
comes with
four premium Central Coast
single‐varietal wines,
and Erlenmeyer flask, measuring
pipette, and instruction manual.
It's everything you'll need
to experiment with wine blends
until you've created
a result you love
and is uniquely personal to you.
Once you've identified
your perfect wine,
simply log on to our website
to upload your favorite blend,
design your original label,
and order your very own
personalized wine.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome
to Blendtique Wine Company,
and welcome to your wine.
We're gonna invite
Kevin and Barbara up here
to have a little blending trial,
a little competition.
‐Ooh, yummy.
‐Absolutely.
‐I'm all for it.
‐And we're gonna
walk you through the process.
In this case, if we were
gonna be doing it
as part of a blending class,
uh, we would obviously be
taking the evening to do it.
If we were gonna be
doing it as a date night,
this is something you could do,
um, from the comfort of home
and take your time.
And yes, of course,
get familiar with the wines.
I will be
blending a Meritage.
Beautiful!
Well, so, you have
the Merlot in front of you.
I'm gonna encourage you to taste
each of the individual wines.
So then, we're gonna move on
to the Cabernet Sauvignon.
We're really trying to
de‐mystify the wine experience.
Cab Sauv is part of my
Meritage blend I'll be creating.
Wonderful.
‐He's such a snob.
‐And then we're going to
move on to the ‐‐
‐Barbara's gonna fall over.
Herjavec: Yeah, Barbara's
already drunk!
I can't tell you how much
I'm into this pitch.
[ Laughter ]
I want you
to know I'm in.
Okay, wonderful!
Barbara, would this be a good
date for you and Kevin?
You know, already I'm
falling in love with him.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna actually have
a little competition.
So, you guys are gonna create
your favorite blend here.
‐Cheers, Lori.
And then, our remaining panel of
Sharks are gonna be our judges.
He's got
all the tools in play.
I'm just fine‐tuning this
amazing Meritage I've created.
Now, Mark, just so
you know, 'cause I know
you're just wondering ‐‐
a Meritage takes
the skill of a master.
A member of
the Chevaliers Du Tastevin.
Chevaliers Du Tastevin!
I have created
the O'Leary Meritage.
Wonderful!
And it is nectar
from the nipple of Aphrodite.
[ Laughs ]
I'm ready to compete with
the swill that Barbara has.
Bring it on!
And it should be
a blind taste test.
That's what we want to do.
Yeah, so, we're gonna do
a little mixing behind my back,
and we're not gonna
know who's is who.
Is she drinking
out of a straw?
‐[ Laughs ] Oh, God.
‐Barbara!
And now we're supposed
to drink that?
I can't watch that.
‐Ah.
‐No more dates with you.
‐She loves her blend.
‐Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Amazing!
Barbara,
can I try your blend?
Oh! Oh!
Oh, that's swill!
All right, are you ready?
I can't see, I can't see!
‐All right, thank you.
‐Lori doesn't have one.
‐Yeah. Good.
‐Okay.
So, which one's...
Oh, that's nasty!
I have a definite winner.
Okay, so wine number one...
Horrible!
How many people like wine one?
‐Me.
And how many people
like wine two?
Obviously, the remaining.
All right,
who's the winner, Billy?
I got to know!
In this case, Barbara,
you beat out Kevin.
‐Impossible.
‐Oh, my God!
Impossible!
‐Impossible.
‐That's hilarious.
So much for
the Chevaliers Du Tastevin!
Listen, this is all
part of the fun.
There's no way Barb blended
a better wine than me.
‐He says there's no way...
‐Of course I did.
‐...Barb blended better.
‐It's crap.
Okay, you're going way
off in the weeds because
several of us
are starting to feel it.
So you've got to
get right to the point.
Do you have sales?
So, we've been in business
for a little over two years.
In that timeframe, we've done
about $200,000 in sales.
‐Oh, that's not bad.
‐However ‐‐
So, Billy,
how do I find this?
Is this a subscrishon ‐‐
I can't even talk anymore.
Is this
a subscription service?
How do you
send it to me?
We have an e‐commerce business
where we have a website
that we do direct
to consumer online.
How much is it?
Uh, the kit right now
retail goes for about $99.
Billy, what's your cost
on that kit?
So, on this kit,
it is about $35 per unit.
So your margin's okay.
Margin's okay.
You said you were
doing classes.
Is that a revenue source
for you right now?
So, that's ‐‐ that's
a big part of where
the program has
actually evolved to.
What we've found is that
a big, big application
for this business
is actually in the hotel,
hospitality,
and catering industry.
Right.
And in particular,
the cruise lines.
So, that's ‐‐ that's
really the direction
we really want to go.
Look, Billy, that's taking you
in a whole different direction.
Right, I don't get the ‐‐
But it's a huge
revenue‐maker for us.
I see the upside
there, right,
but that's not what
you came in with, right?
You didn't come in and say,
"Look, we are gonna just
crush it with experiential
classrooms where people get to
have fun with wine."
You came in selling fun
of the experience at home.
That is not the path
of least resistance
in any way, shape, or form.
I'm out.
I thought
you were selling fun.
Of course we are!
Somewhere along the way,
the end‐user goal was
to sell a bottle of wine.
Then, I heard
wine classes.
the hospitality business.
But it sounds to me like
you're going in many directions.
Don't waste
your breath on me.
It's just not a business
that I understand or enjoy.
I'm out.
You came in here ‐‐
I kind of thought this was
a party‐favor kit.
And you are having
a great experience for that.
Let me tell you,
that great experience ‐‐
I almost wanted
to kiss Kevin.
That's how happy I became.
[ Laughs ]
What do I pay for
my case of wine?
Once I develop my own wine,
I want to get it.
So, if you're ‐‐ if you're
buying a full case of your wine,
uh, you're looking at $300.
‐Ouch!
‐Wow.
‐Wait a minute.
‐Billy, how many bottles
in a case?
‐So what's in ‐‐ yeah.
12 bottles.
‐Is that a lot?
‐$25 a bottle.
But if I've done that party
in my home that I just did,
what percentage of those folks
order a case of wine?
Currently, the purchase rate
is about 15%.
I think 15% is
a terrible conversion rate
on something like that.
I don't see you selling
a lot of wine so sadly,
I've enjoyed the party,
sweetheart,
[clicks tongue]
but I'm out.
Billy, I spend a ton
of time in the wine business.
It's a tough business.
And 97% in America of wine is
sold for under $13.90 a bottle.
You will never sell wine
for over 14 bucks a bottle.
Narrator: Three Sharks are out,
and Kevin is concerned
about the high price point
for Billy's wine
novelty product, Blendtique.
‐$25 a bottle.
‐Ouch.
You will never sell wine
for over 14 bucks a bottle.
You have to remember though,
this is really
a hand‐craft item.
‐I get it.
‐Yeah, but people don't
respect that or appreciate that.
You should've captured me
in this business.
I mean, my goodness.
But when I saw
what you were selling it...
I don't think it's too late.
I really believe that you'll...
No, no, it's too late.
I'm out.
I'm out, I'm out.
What I'm sitting here
thinking about is,
I love it as a gift.
I love it as something
that people can do
as an experience together
just to have fun.
Of course.
But my concern is
your price point.
Can you get this down
to $49.99?
Yes.
And then, can you
get your bottle to,
I don't know,
$13 a bottle?
I would say if we ship it
direct to the consumer, 100%.
Um, I'll give you
a flyer, Billy.
I'll give you a chance.
‐Oh, great!
‐A flyer!
I'll give you $250,000
for 30%.
‐Ouch.
‐That's a little high.
It's a little steep.
So, I have a partner.
Yeah.
He would want me to counter
with, um, $250,000 for 15%.
I like you, Billy.
I'm taking a chance, 'cause
there's a lot of "ifs."
I know I can help you.
The lowest I'll go ‐‐
I will go $250,000 for 25%.
It's up to you.
You need a workhorse.
I'm a Clydesdale.
So, my investor is actually
a bit of a Shark himself.
He's been in it with me
from the get‐go.
The only thing I could
consider doing would be
to dilute my shares beyond
what he is offering
to dilute on his side.
‐What are your shares, Billy?
‐That's a commitment
right there.
‐'Cause I don't want to do
something that is
wrong for you.
I own 49%.
So, if you would be willing
to meet in the middle
at $250,000 for 20%,
I would dilute my remaining
percentage down
to meet you at that level.
What if I do this
where I give you a loan?
I give you
a $250,000 loan.
I take 8% interest,
10% equity.
‐There you go.
‐And I do it like that.
That's a lot better than
it sounds 'cause you get her.
I would like
to do that deal with you.
‐Yes!
‐Yay!
Mazel Tov!
‐Let's have a drink!
‐Yay, whoo!
What did I tell you?
Thank you.
It's a great gift.
It's super fun.
Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you very much.
Thanks, Billy.
Dim: So, having Lori on board,
being able to really
highlight and market and share
the product with the world
just because of her exposure
and being who she is
and her relationships ‐‐
it's gonna be invaluable to us.
Herjavec:
I was born in Croatia,
which was a Communist country
when I was there
called Yugoslavia.
We had dirt floors and hay
and no running water
for a long time,
but it never seemed bad
'cause I was a little kid,
and my grandmother,
lots of family,
dogs, cats, horses.
You never know the situation
you grow up in
until you compare it
to something else.
Yugoslavia was a great country,
if you were part
of the Communist Party.
My dad was very anti‐Communist,
and would say all kinds
of bad things about Communism.
And he got thrown in jail
22 times,
and the last time
he got thrown in, he was told,
"If you come back,
you will never return."
He packed a suitcase,
grabbed my mom and me,
and we crossed the border
to Italy, got on a boat,
and came to Canada.
In Yugoslavia,
my dad was such a happy guy.
He was a manager,
and he was pretty up there.
He was well‐respected
for what he did.
He then he comes to Canada,
and he's sweeping floors
in a factory.
He was never the same.
I think I'm like
every other kid.
You never appreciate your
parents un‐‐ until they're gone.
And I just think
how hard he worked
to give me that opportunity.
And I just feel such a need
to justify that sacrifice.
I had lots of dreams
when I was growing up.
I wanted to be a detective,
a vet, a race car driver.
I was so unfocused.
My best friend went for this
interview at a computer company,
and I'm thinking,
"Computers ‐‐ who cares?
Boring!"
Until he says
the starting salary is $30,000.
I'm like, "What?"
And he says,
"Well, I didn't get the job.
Here's the guy's number.
Call him."
That's how I got started
in the computer business.
The Herjavec Group
is one of the world's
largest
cyber‐security companies.
I'm really passionate about it,
because it feels like
we do good.
I really think
the world is changing.
The Internet has a lot of good,
but it has a lot
of potential bad.
And by protecting companies,
we're making the world
a safer place.
I think what makes me different
than the other Sharks
is I'm an actual immigrant.
I actually came here on a boat.
That shapes a lot of
how I think and who I am.
People think today,
"Oh, I can't get ahead.
It's really hard."
Yeah, damn right it's really
hard, and it should be hard.
Entrepreneurship
is the great equalizer.
It's not about
who your parents are.
It's not about your color.
It's not about you sex.
It's not about your religion.
You know, business
doesn't really care.
Business only cares about
the value that you add.
I'm proud of
the success I've had,
but only in the sense
that it justifies
the sacrifice from my parents.
To work that hard
and go through that much pain,
and then for me to squander
it and not do something
with my life ‐‐ that would've
been undeserving for them.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a unique way
to control your appetite.
Hi.
I'm Mark Bernstein.
I'm from San Francisco,
and I'm the founder
and C. E. O. of MealEnders.
We're seeking $350,000
for 8% of our company.
Sharks, it happens all the time.
We say we're gonna
control our weight,
but the next thing we know,
we're going for seconds
and even thirds.
We know overeating is bad,
but it's hard to
control ourselves sometimes.
Until now.
MealEnders are a totally new
approach to weight management.
Signaling lozenges that
combine behavioral psychology
and sensory science to help you
beat overeating,
master portion control,
and curb snacking.
Each MealEnder has two layers ‐‐
an outer reward layer
which provides
a measured dose of dessert
to cue the end of a meal
and satisfy snack cravings.
The inner cooling and tingling
core clears your palette
and transitions your focus
away from eating
until your natural
fullness signals kick in.
This unique formula rewards
and then resets your taste buds,
freeing you from the desire
to over‐indulge,
all without drugs
or harmful stimulants.
So, Sharks,
give MealEnders a try.
Take control
and get over overeating.
I have some samples
for you to try.
Yeah, let's try it.
So, the product is designed
to dissolve in your mouth.
No chewing, or...
No chewing?
‐No chewing.
So, there's different
flavors here?
Different flavors ‐‐
chocolate mint, mocha,
citrus, and cinnamon.
‐Thank you.
‐You're probably not gonna
want to have more than one.
‐I have to tell you, it's deli‐‐
‐It's really...
‐It tastes good.
‐Delicious chocolate.
But wait till you get to the ‐‐
the active taste layer.
‐Getting there.
‐How many calories?
15 calories,
2 grams of sugar.
I'm getting
to the hard candy.
What you're gonna
start to experience
is this cooling and tingling.
And there's a small percentage
of the population that, uh...
I actually got a tingle
through my body.
I feel ‐‐ I feel
the cooling core,
and all of a sudden ‐‐ Barbara,
you look very attractive!
[ Laughter ]
Give me a kiss.
‐Ew!
I just feel
warm and fuzzy.
Oh, it's burning
a little.
Well, hopefully
that's tingling.
‐It's like a chilly...
‐It leaves kind of a funky taste
on your tongue.
‐Well, remember, the obje‐‐
Which, at this point,
is making me not want
to put anything else
in my mouth...
‐Exactly.
‐... because my tongue feels
funny, and it's like it kills
your taste buds, right?
Well, some people
love the taste.
It's getting
really strong now.
‐We've only had...
‐It's getting really bad.
‐Yeah, it's uncomfortable.
‐It's like a bad date.
At the beginning,
she's wonderful.
This is the end of the date,
and I really hate her.
Cuban: Yeah, she's sticking
that thing in your mouth,
and it's like when
you brush your teeth
and she's got morning breath.
Let me tell you how it works,
but I want to tell you
one data point.
We've been in the market
for a year and a half.
We've had less than 2% returns.
We have 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
What's your sales
in a year and a half?
$1.4 million.
‐You've done $1.4 million!
‐Where are you selling?
Yeah, only on our website
and on Amazon.
What can you sell
this for online?
So, it depends on
what quantity you buy it in ‐‐
anywhere from
$16.95 for one bag,
and if you buy in quantity
on a continuity plan,
it goes down to $8.99.
‐It's pretty pricey,
but you know what
I like about it?
I sat here trying to think,
"What would I like to eat
right now to get rid of
that bad taste?"
And I couldn't
think of a single thing.
Right.
And that's a cool little trick
for people who like
to overeat.
Are you a scientist?
What's going on?
‐I am not a scientist.
‐How did you create this?
I am someone who
needed the product.
I started going to the doctor
every year as I got older,
which I'm sure many of you
might have experienced.
So, doctor would look at
one number and say,
"Why don't you lose 10 pounds?"
So I became more conscious
of my own eating,
and I experienced
that my problem was stopping.
And so I started looking for
some product that would
help me stop.
And I had the idea, and I said,
"Boy, if somebody could develop
something like that,
that would be a great business."
So I went and engaged
the leading food‐development
company in the country.
Mark, how much weight
did you lose on this?
I lost 15 pounds.
And you've kept it off?
Yeah, and for me,
it's mindfulness.
Okay, tell me what
the customers are saying.
So, we did a test with
a third‐party testing arm,
and the results there came back
better than we had hoped.
Over 75% stopped eating sooner,
avoided snacking,
and lost weight.
So you're not ‐‐ you know,
so you could've...
We've had 6,000 reorders,
21% of our...
But does it have to
taste like that?
Well, everyone's
taste is different.
There's a reason why you walk
into a restaurant...
21% of your people reordered,
is what you're saying?
So far.
Greiner:
How much have you invested?
My family has,
uh, $200,000 in it.
Anybody else, or do we
have any other investors?
Yeah, we've done
a convertible note round,
and we've raised,
uh, $1.1 million.
‐Ooh!
‐Wow!
‐Wow.
‐Including my money.
Have you made a profit
from the very beginning
till now, at all?
Uh, we haven't been running
the business to run a profit.
Over the last few months, we've
had some profitable months,
but basically we're putting
everything back.
‐How much did you ‐‐
‐We're trying to grow
the top line, because
we know that the power...
So, you're reinvesting
in advertising?
We're now doing
significant advertising.
Specifically, what were
your sales last month?
$170,000.
And this month will be close
to $175,000 or north of there.
Okay. And what have you spent
on advertising per month?
Probably, uh, about
half ‐‐ half of that.
Half of that number?
‐Wow.
‐Or a little bit less.
What we're doing is ‐‐
But still,
anything close, right?
21% reordering
is horrible.
It's horrific.
This should be viral.
Well, we think it is
starting to get viral.
No, it can't.
It's not viral if you have to
spend half your revenue
in advertising.
Look, we're a brand‐new company
that no one's ever heard of.
No, you're not.
You're 18 months in,
and you have over
a million dollars in sales.
Well, we didn't start
advertising till later.
This should be the most
viral product ever.
If just one person
loses 15 pounds,
what are they gonna do?
They're gonna
get asked by everybody,
"What did you do?
What did you do?
What did you do," right?
I ‐‐ I think you've
got a good idea.
I see what you're
trying to accomplish.
But you don't have
the solution yet.
I'm out.
Everybody in the world
wants to be rich,
and everybody in the world
wants to be thin.
But very few people
want to put the effort in.
So, when you have
a trigger point,
I think it really helps.
And I think you're
really on to something.
Here's what I don't
like about it.
It's kind of in the supplement,
diet kind of business.
You're gonna spend
a fortune to get the word out,
and then one day, there's
a hot new thing out there.
I don't like
that business.
I wish you all the best,
but I think you're gonna burn
a lot of money
to get to scale.
I'm out.
Can I share a couple
of facts with you?
One, the scale
of this problem is enormous.
Yeah, we know that,
but that's not the challenge.
Mark, let me take
a stab at it.
‐Okay.
‐You know, this is the first
weight‐reduction product that's
ever come on to "Shark Tank"
and not been just
torn to shreds.
Yeah, true.
You didn't make claims
that you couldn't support.
You gave us the theory
behind the product.
I buy into it.
I personally don't like
the cooling, tingling core.
It's that simple,
and for me to give you $350,000,
I got to like the product.
And I just don't think
I'm sticking another one
of those things
in my mouth again.
And for that reason
and that reason only, I'm out.
Herjavec:
Lori, what are you gonna do?
I didn't like it either,
actually.
I wish you good luck,
but for me,
this isn't a product that
I feel very confident about.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Barbara,
what are you doing?
You know what?
My experience on my tongue
was terrific,
and psychologically, I get it.
I'm amazed at your sales,
but you've infused the business
with a lot of cash,
and I think your
just getting started
is gonna take too much money
to make this enough.
We actually have people
who are interested in investing.
So because of those reasons,
although I love
your product, I'm out.
Okay.
‐Thanks, Mark.
‐Good luck, Mark.
Thanks, guys.
They are celebrities.
They're thin, they're fit,
they have trainers.
Not everybody has that.
And this is a product
that can help people who don't,
perhaps, go on
"Dancing with the Stars."
Mark, what do you
think about Kevin
on "Dancing with the Stars"?
I would love it.
You would lose 25 pounds
like that.
You've got it,
and I'm gonna kick your ass.
[ Laughs ]
Biggest thing?
What?
The biggest thing
we need ‐‐ energy.
Energy.
Push‐ups?
Mm!
Let's do this,
baby!
Yo!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a business that recycles
otherwise wasted materials.
Hello, Sharks!
My name's Alec Avedissian.
And I'm his
younger brother, Aric.
We're from
Ventura County, California,
and our company is Rareform.
We're seeking $300,000
for a 10% stake in our company.
Imagine you're sitting
in traffic on the freeway,
and you look up
and you see
a colorful, bold
billboard advertisement.
In L. A. alone, there are
over 10,000 billboards,
and those billboards
are typically swapped out
every four to six weeks
and then thrown away.
What you might not know,
though, is that billboards
are actually made of
a heavy‐duty,
durable waterproof vinyl ‐‐
the perfect material
for making a bag,
but bad for our landfills.
This is where
Rareform comes in.
We intercept that material
before it reaches the landfill,
and turn it into one‐of‐a‐kind
bags and accessories.
Out of one billboard alone,
we can get 1,000 wallets,
10 bulk surfboard bags,
or 100 unique backpacks.
Our customers love
that they're truly getting
one‐of‐a‐kind products that are
helping sustain our environment.
Sharks, we were lucky enough
to get our hands on a billboard
from our favorite show...
[ Laughter ]
...and we turned it into
products just for you guys.
We'd love for you
to check them out.
So, Robert, we got you
a surfboard bag.
Oh, thank you!
Wow, very cool!
This one says, "Only
the strong will survive" on it.
‐I like that. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
Lori, look at this!
‐Really cool.
‐It's really cool!
‐I want Mark's.
‐Yeah, I'll swap with you.
Are these each a slice
of the billboard?
Yeah, so, a typical billboard
is around, like, 14x48 feet.
So, it's as big
as this room, almost.
How did you get to this?
Where ‐‐ where'd you come from?
After college, I moved
to El Salvador and I was working
with a non‐profit down there
in a small fishing village.
And a buddy of mine showed me
a tote bag that was actually
made out of a billboard.
And he was like,
"We use this as roofing."
They were using it
as actual like shelter,
and we were down there
surfing...
‐Wow.
‐A billboard.
...and my buddy said, "Let's
make a surfboard bag out of it."
I didn't know where
to find a sewer,
and I found
somebody across the street
that, you know, could sew up...
Car upholstery.
...car upholstery.
And I took
my surfboard and said,
"Can you help us make a bag?"
And from there, we made a bag,
and our first retailer store...
Our friends loved it.
... yeah, our first
retailer store that we actually
got into was Patagonia stores.
Wow.
So, we're at Patagonia stores
in the U. S.
and Patagonia stores
in Japan.
Who takes them down?
Is there...
So, the outdoor marketing
company takes it down.
So, what we do is
we have supply contracts
with the two largest
outdoor marketing companies.
And do you have exclusive
contracts with them?
We do.
Okay.
Corcoran: How many billboards
do those two contracts
obligate you to buy?
You're committed
in advance?
They're actually free.
We don't buy them.
‐Oh, free!
‐So, the big thing for us is
we now gave them
an opportunity
to cost‐save
on their business.
At the same time, they promote
it to their, like, PR side.
But you have to
transport it, right?
So, transporting
the material from us,
we get about 1,000 billboards,
and it costs around $200.
What is the cost on a knapsack,
a carrier bag, a wallet?
Well, what you have, Robert ‐‐
that's our surfboard bag.
That was our main product
we started with.
That costs us $12 to make.
We wholesale for $40,
retail for $80.
To make a wallet ‐‐ that's our
best‐selling product ‐‐
it's $2, and we wholesale
for $12.50.
Guys, how do you
communicate the message?
'Cause the reality is,
if you just look at that,
you have no idea
that it's a billboard.
And then, when you just
feel it, you know,
if you didn't know
it was a billboard,
you'd be like,
"What's up with this thing?
It doesn't feel right."
So, the biggest part,
I feel, about Rareform,
is they love
the story behind it.
And that's the biggest thing
we have is trouble
is telling that story
to our new...
Right, and that's
the big question.
‐Who's telling it?
Who's telling it for you?
So, on our website, you know,
we tell it on our website ‐‐
it's pretty easy.
But in‐store, we have
to come out with
the best displays possible
to help tell that story ‐‐
any kind of
point‐of‐purchases displays.
Well, I don't see anything
there. What do you guys do?
So, for us right now,
like, for example,
these are in every Quicksilver
store ‐‐ a wallet display.
And these turn great for us.
What are your sales?
That's a great question.
So far...
I think it's a very good
question.
I like it a lot, actually.
Yeah, it is
a good one.
We've done $1.1 million
in sales.
Over what period of time?
This is our third year
in business.
So, what did you do
in the last 12 months?
Last 12 months,
we did $700,000.
But you guys are
making money then, right?
Because your margins are decent,
and $700,000 in sales.
No, so, last year,
we actually took a loss.
‐You did?
‐Yeah, we took a $130,000 loss.
‐Why?
‐Damn!
‐Because we were
manufacturing products
still in the U. S.,
so it wasn't until
the last four months
that we moved to Mexico
and have cut our costs down.
For example, like Aric
was saying on the surfbag,
it was costing us $28.
‐And what's it costing now?
‐Now, $12.
‐$12.
‐And your wholesale
for the surfbag is...
‐$40.
So a 70% mark‐up.
Right, so you've got
70% margins.
Yes.
So last month,
you should've made money.
Yeah, we did. Actually, it was
a turning point in our company.
‐How much did you make?
‐Uh, I think it was like, 5K.
‐Yeah!
Where'd you get the money
to absorb the loss?
So, in the beginning,
I put in $60,000,
and Aric put in $20,000.
I put in $20,000.
Do you have
any other investors?
Yeah, we first raised around
$200,000 prior to revenue.
From family and friends,
or from whom?
Uh. from family
and friends, yeah.
What did
you value that at?
What was the value of business
after they put the $200,000 in?
Uh, I want
to say it was at ‐‐
I'm not totally sure
on that number.
You should know that.
‐$105,000.
‐How much equity did they get?
‐They got 30% equity.
‐How much do you have?
‐They got 30%?
‐And then, you guys split
the 70% equally?
Right now, Alec and I own
around 40% of the company.
So, the value of the business
was $600,000 on that.
We actually just raised
another round,
and it was at
a $2.5 million valuation.
Oh!
$2.5 million for this?
How much did you raise?
$150,000.
Wow.
You're asking me to give you
$300,000 for 10%
impugning a $3 million value.
No chance in hell
it's worth $3 million.
Another big aspect
for our business
that we haven't talked on
is that we have
a corporate business.
We just got a first P. O.
from one of the largest
theme parks in the world.
Um, here's my thing.
You don't own enough stock.
I feel like at this point,
you've sold off a chunk of
your business again and again.
That concerns me.
All right, I don't
think there's enough room
for another person to come in
and take a bite.
So, I'm out.
All right.
Appreciate it.
It's your personal touch
that has a lot to do
with what's going on,
and that's very hard to scale.
And you're not asking
for $100,000
for 30% of your business.
You're asking for a valuation
for a real company
that needs to grow
into very significant profits
in order for me
to get my money back.
‐Yeah.
‐So, for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
Listen, you've done
$1.1 million in three years,
so nobody can scoff at that.
That's really good.
And I do love that the, um,
environmentally‐friendly
piece of it, which is great.
You're recycling these.
But, because it's ever‐changing,
you're never gonna have
two of the same twice.
It's a bad thing, because if
I see yours and I love it,
and I want one, I can't
get one because they're unique.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
If part of your deal
in getting these billboards
was some kind of a license
or a contract
where you could
market them that way,
then you have a unique,
sustainable position.
But a $3 million value
and not having that in place ‐‐
I don't see it.
I'm out.
Okay, guys, that leaves me.
I like you guys.
You're grinders.
But the biggest problem
with your deal is the valuation
and the fact you don't
own much equity anymore.
You're not worth $3 million.
I don't care what
other people paid for it.
You're not profitable yet.
Um, here's the only way
to do this.
I'm gonna offer you
$300,000 as debt,
8% interest rate, 36 months.
That's three years.
That's enough to prove out
your model and get sales going,
and you're gonna
give me 10% equity,
which you offered
when you walked in the Tank.
That's the only deal here,
and it's the only one
you've got.
You got to make a decision.
What do you want to do?
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Kevin is Aric and Alec's
last chance for a deal
for their bags made from
recycled billboards, Rareform.
I'm gonna offer you
$300,000 as debt,
8% interest rate, 36 months.
That's three years.
That's enough to prove out
your model and get sales going,
and you're gonna give me
10% equity,
which you offered when
you walked in the Tank.
That's the only deal here,
and it's the only you've got.
You got to make a decision.
What do you want to do?
What if we were to do it ‐‐
just structure it as a ‐‐
an equity deal instead?
And what if we moved
the percentage?
It is an equity deal.
I'm getting 10%.
15%, yeah.
But I'm loaning you the money.
You are not ‐‐ guys, you're just
not worth 3 million bucks.
You're also very quick to give
away stock ‐‐ bam, like that.
That's scary.
For us, I mean,
we didn't have any other way
to start the business.
For us...
You know, if it was
straight equity,
I would ask for about
40% of your company, okay?
And if you do that,
you simply don't own enough
to get up and go to work.
I don't want to do that.
That's not good for me.
It's useless.
Once I loan you money, I'm at
risk, do you understand that?
I've got to get it back.
I don't want you to fail.
No, we understand it.
I think the big thing for me
is the balloon payment.
I think, I mean, I would like
to have it, you know,
kicked back like, five months.
When you borrow money,
my friend,
you got to pay it back one day.
How much do you
need the cash today?
I mean, right now,
we're at a place
where we do need the cash,
'cause we're ‐‐
If you need the cash,
it's a great offer.
It's not a balloon payment.
You're paying it along the way.
Everybody's gonna
charge you that.
I'm not gonna do something
that hurts the business
that I'm trying
to support.
‐Yeah.
‐That's stupid money.
I'm not stupid.
I know how to lend money.
Corcoran:
I think he's being overpaid.
You just think about that,
young man.
He gets a kicker at the end,
he takes a chunk
of your business ‐‐ 10%.
You don't own
a lot already.
And he's being overpaid
on the interest,
even though he's positioning it
as a great deal.
You think 8%
is being overpaid?
Yes.
Barbara, why don't you
make an offer
if you're so generous?
‐I'm not!
‐It's the only offer, Barbara.
What's going through
your heads right now?
I think that, you know,
the 8% interest is pretty high.
What if we were to get it
somewhere down 5%?
It's not high.
I ‐‐ are you kidding?
Have you tried to factor
any of your receivables yet?
He says he does.
Yeah, we have a factor.
What are you getting for it?
6%.
I don't believe it.
I'd like to see those terms.
‐If we show you those terms ‐‐
‐I do not believe you, actually.
‐We'll show you the terms.
‐There you go.
‐There's your counter.
‐So you're saying that you can
go do the very same thing
at 6% right now.
‐Yeah.
‐Zero interest.
You're just not worth it yet.
No, thanks.
What are you gonna do?
What do you feel
in your gut?
By the way, I didn't say ‐‐
and you probably know this ‐‐
I'm extremely valuable.
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
‐You got to deal with him.
‐Oh, my God.
He didn't say
valuable to who.
Oh, my God.
Let me get the shovel.
Ask any of my entrepreneurs,
any of them.
They ‐‐ I am Mr. Wonderful
to them.
Uh...
Let's do it.
Wow, you're gonna
regret that one.
‐Hey!
‐What?
Okay, guys. I think
you made a wise decision.
I'm not kidding.
Thank you.
Remember, you're gonna have to
look at that face every day.
Congratulations, guys.
Good luck.
Whoo!
All right!
Alec: We're still learning
how to run the business
more efficiently,
more effectively,
and having somebody
with that wisdom
that we can call on
and talk with
is really just gonna be
a game‐changer for us.
And he seems like
a great man, too.
I kind of want
to party with him.
Yeah.
I want to rub
that bald head of his.
Just rub that thing.
[ Laughs ]